[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
un jeune yves les noirs enfin d'origine
yvelinoise qui est auteur et acteur d'un
spectacle un son spectacle bien sûr il
s'appelle guillaume l'oublier guillaume
l'oublier bonjour jours merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation sur le plateau
de tv 78 pour ce vide que nous allons
entièrement vous consacrez voilà c'est
un bon match à meaux vous avez une
actualité plutôt brûlante en ce moment
vous proposer un spectacle qui s'appelle
un ailleurs elvis intelligence et rire
d'accord voilà on voit la fiche
d'ailleurs derrière nous ce spectacle se
joue tous les samedis soirs au théâtre
la flèche rue de charonne dans le 11e ça
c'est dit et je vous propose qu'on ne
regarde déjà la bande annonce et on en
reparle après ok ils veulent une
démonstration je m'en veulent en faire
une de démonstration mais façon jacques
nous n'allons pas faire comme jacques
qui ne voudrait surtout pas de
technologie par peur de tomber dans
l'agout gueule du loup
à l'heure de la vie internet je m'en
vais rappeler l'importance de la vie
intérieure nous sommes à l'aube d'une
situation sociale inédite et je m'engage
dès maintenant à vous en présenter les
grandes lignes prenons des exemples
concrets
[Musique]
quand on a une minute devant soi on l'a
pas ce soit à régler un problème soit à
créer le futur quand on choisit de créer
le futur on a plus de problème ces
femmes et enfants la différence entre
les auteurs qui disent des choses que
les gens ont envie d'entendre et ceux
qui disent des choses que les gens ont
besoin d'entendre c'est ainsi que j'ai
écrit tous mes bouquins moi c'est pour
cette raison d'ailleurs que j'en ai
vendu aucun
pourquoi et bien parce que ce qu'on a
besoin d'entendre on en a pas l'envi
alors qu'on devrait avoir envie
d'entendre les choses dont on a besoin
on se crée des fonds besoin et on fait
tout pour qu'il nous donne envie et là
vous auriez besoin que je répète mais
j'en ai pas envie
et puis qui sait qu'il veut un selphy
avec le beau gosse ce
jeu tendance à offrir aux autres des
cadeaux qui me font plaisir à moi ça va
ça vous plaît le poème
j'aimerais être un humain une créature
complète et parfaite au contraire ma
chérie au contraire le contre de l'homme
fait naître génialement appareils
voilà donc c'était la bande annonce de r
votre spectacle actuellement à la fiche
alors vous avez déjà inscrit des
spectacles où c'est le premier par
exemple c'est le premier c'est le
premier j'avais collaboré à l'écriture
sur un autre spectacle mais c'est le
premier vraiment que j'ai écrit tout
seul comme un grand d'accord alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous le résumer
en deux trois phrases bien sûr voilà
c'est l'histoire d'un vieux philosophe
jacques qui assistait de simone son
robot lutte pour que les hommes gardent
leur humanité dans un monde de plus en
plus connecté le faire une démonstration
scientifique sur la l'importance de la
nécessité des émotions humaines mais
cette démonstration va être piratée
interrompu par pierre le techno
scientifique son rival et et voilà et
c'est une rivalité entre deux
scientifiques qui d'accord qui ont des
visions du monde différentes d'accord
alors comment vous avez eu l'idée
d'écrire un tel spectacle vous avez été
frappé par quelque chose dont on a
l'impression que c'est une sorte d'
alerte tout de même oui bah en fait on
ne peut pas faire comme s'il ne se
passait rien au niveau technologique
c'est vrai que la technologie s'invite
dans nos vies avec une facilité une
rapidité incroyable à la salle de sport
on fait nos abdos en consultant nos
mails chez soi on en parle à une
insanité intelligente dans certaines
villes on ne peut pas marcher sans
tomber sur un écran numérique on a
l'impression que rien ne freine
l'expansion du numérique qu'ils
colonisent tous les pans notre existence
et on est en droit de se demander si ça
va s'arrêter un jour parce que la
technologie est un moteur de croissance
aucun gouvernement n'a de raison de
ralentir son développement et même s'il
existe des comités d'éthique qui
analysent l'acceptabilité des
réalisations techniques et bien il ya
une incitation à l'innovation qui est
encouragé par les décideurs politiques
industrielles et donc on est dans un
monde plus en plus de technologies et
au delà de cet usage quotidien qu'on a
de la technologie vous comme moi eh bien
il ya des gens qui désirent l'utiliser
pour améliorer l'espèce humaine la fait
revivre ça c'est important voilà
effectivement ce sont deux choses
différentes mais de faim c'est pour moi
c'est lié évidemment puisque c'est un
rapport à la technologie c'est comme si
on avait un amour inconditionnel pour la
technologie ou alors une inconscience
une ignorance de du monde et de l'humain
qu'on façonne à mesure qu'on eut des
conséquences et de ses conséquences
évidemment que tu danger potentiel voilà
fait et donc vous mettez donc en
opposition la science dure et la science
molle tout à fait est-ce qu'on peut
juste dire ce que c'est une bonne
question alors si la professeure j'ai
pas expert du effectivement
grossièrement la chance dur ce sont les
sciences formelle exact le sciences de
la nature
mathématiques physique biologie là et la
science molle dites douces aussi ce sont
les sciences sociales et humaines alors
c'est pas lorsque la science dure et
dure qu'elle est inhumaine et c'est pas
parce que la chance est molle qu'elle
est inexact je comprends très bien et
alors vous avez donc structurer votre
spectacle avec donc ces deux fameux
savant qui s'affrontent ce robot qui qui
répond qui est sur scène voilà qui est
la preuve vivante de la technologie
envahit de plus en plus nos espaces et
vous avez créé une galerie de cinq
personnages je crois tout à fait alors
quels sont ils et bien donc il ya
jacques le philosophe il y a simone le
robot interprétée par laura charpentier
qui a fait la mise en scène je vais
permet tout à fait qui fait également la
mise en scène il y a balthazard un
chanteur lyrique qui a un gros problème
dans sa vie de couple il y à pompons qui
a un gros problème avec lui et même avec
des pulsions sexuelles beaucoup trop
depuis trop intense il y à garda une
femme d'origine allemande qui s'est fait
trompée par son mari et qui doit prendre
la parole lors d'une assemblée et qui
qui est dans un pathétique hilarant
pierre le techno scientifique et
d'accord et vous les avez choisi en
fonction de quoi se sont pour vous des
archétypes de la société actuelle ça
représente des problèmes humains alors
en fait jacques va donc le philosophe
oui mais moi je voulais savoir déjà les
trois personnages le caire d'affaires et
bien je dois faire apparaître des
personnages oui pour parler d'humanité
une humanité plein d'instabilité pleine
d'imperfections et moi sur le plein
d'émotions exactement et les émotions
nous rendent instable mais ce sont des
émotions qui donne de la saveur à nos
vies qui rendent les journées enfin qui
font que les journées ne se ressemblent
pas qu'il faut notre humanité et qui
fait notre humanité effectivement si
l'humanité égale instabilité
imprévisibilité oui par rapport à la
machine qui elle est prévisible et
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un monde où
avec les systèmes algorithmiques qui
nous renvoie des publicités selon nos
consultations internet et bien on est de
plus en plus amenés à considérer
l'humain comme un être de plus en plus
prévisible très qui appartenait jusque
là mans jusqu'à maintenant pendant qu'à
la machine étant dit qu'on se regarde de
plus en plus comme des êtres mécanique
on se met à traiter nos robots comme des
êtres de plus en plus relationnel et
donc ce mouvement un peu étrange que
j'interroge voilà à travers aussi des
personnages très humain voilà voilà
justement pour qui cette confrontation
c'est un peu forte et qu'on réalise que
finalement on tend à rendre l'homme le
plus proche possible du robot finalement
en lui enlevant ses émotions oui on si
oui exactement wifi non mais voilà non
mais c'est à dire que je ne pointe du
doigt personne si ce n'est nous en fait
les citoyens et puis ce système qui qui
est dans une espèce d'innovation pour
l'innovation elle même il ya une époque
on innovait pour le bien le bien être du
monde et des citoyens aujourd'hui on
innove par ce que il faut que les
entreprises y nomme et pour ne pas
crever pour ne pas disparaître il ya une
sélection naturelle
etc voilà si la questionner évidemment
que cet axe alors bien sûr et déjà il ya
500 ans notre ami rabelais nous disait
science sans conscience n'est que ruine
de l'âme mais vous c'est ça que vous
souhaitez faire c'est nous donner
conscience de ce phénomène en fait la
zone dite il ya ok il faut déjà le
savoir donc c'est grâce à ce spectacle
on en prend conscience et après vous dit
en être
d'accord ou pas tout à fait mais
quelqu'un fait ça oui tout à fait
exactement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure on est dans un monde de plus en
plus technologies c est cette
technologie on peut qu'admettre que elle
transforme à me dire qu'on utilise notre
rapport à nous aux autres mondes à la
priory dans nos priorités autant à la
géographie on délègue de plus en plus de
tâches aux machines qu'est ce qu'on
gagne qu'est ce qu'on perd on se
conforme des plus en plus au
fonctionnement des machines en les
utilisant si les machines simplifie nos
vies elle nous simplifie aussi d'une
certaine manière et puis il ya ce
mouvement transhumanisme qui prône usage
des sciences et des technologies pour
améliorer augmenté l'humain est donc
effectivement est ce que nous avons
conscience de tout cela est ce que nous
sommes conscients que nous rejetons
certains traits de notre humanité pour
en désir et d'autres ceux des machines
ou si ce n'est pas le cas est-ce que
nous avons conscience que nous sommes en
train de façonner un nouveau monde un
nouvel humains à mesure que nous
utilisons et que nous acceptons ces
micro changement semble en avoir
vraiment conscience mais on se laisse
envahir oui alors c'est pas si pour
péjorative fait négatifs mais c est ce
que nous en avons conscience et si nous
avons conscience c'est ce que nous
sommes en accord paisible avec sa et
est-ce que nous sommes d'accord avec ça
est-ce que nous sommes d'accord avec ce
monde ultra technologie zay je veux dire
on a déjà des prouesses technologiques
qui sont qui sont formidables enfin les
réseaux sociaux sont son superbe pour
pour plein de plans mais les réseaux
sociaux comme la technologie ce sont des
choses qui ne sont pas neutres il ya des
neurosciences derrière qui sont super
forts pour les rendre addictives et
voilà il faut le savoir quoi voilà on
est conscient et voici on est d'accord
ou pas un tercio on adhère ou pas
exactement donc c'est ce que vous avez
souhaité faire avec le spectacle en
mêlant l'humour bien sûr est ce qui est
des c'est un spectacle un peu bon pour
tout le monde bien évidemment j'imagine
des jeunes que qui justement sont à très
très affamé de technologie est ce que ce
ne serait pas bien que voit ce spectacle
si merveilleux mais ce que
je veux dire ils naissent avec ton
qu'ils ont pas le recul de ceux qui ont
connu l'avant comme nous enfin comme moi
totalement sa nage est est ce que je
veux mais oui mais bien sûr mais il ya
des digital
tiff voilà donc ce qui naissent avec la
technologie qui naissent avec le fait de
ce crowley et c'est enfin de se creuser
c'est dans ce sens là mais bien sûr que
c'est important qu'ils voient ce
spectacle en relation avec des
délicieuses justement ce que j'allais
vous dire vous êtes aussi professeur de
théâtre oui enfin en parallèle en temps
vous avez affaire à des jeunes à des
jeunes alors qu'est ce qu'ils disent par
rapport à votre spectacle alors quelle
est votre vision de cette jeunesse le ma
vision de la jeunesse justement étant
prof de théâtre j'essaie de fées
continue de perdurer de pérenniser cette
espèce bas le théâtre c'est à dire là
l'émotion l'humain dans ses
imperfections des et dans sa dans sa
grandeur du main voilà et ça c'est pour
moi c'est l'essence du théâtre car voilà
mais par rapport à mon spectacle il ya
des jeunes qui sont déjà venus le voir
et qui va chemin en apprécier le
spectacle parce qu'il ya un gros bobo
parce qu'il ya de l'humour parce que des
personnages parce que c'est dynamique
très vivant et aussi parce que mercy et
parce que aussi ça parle effectivement
d'une société actuelle d'accord où on
s'y retrouve tous puisque c'est
l'humanité en fait c'est universel ok
bah écoute et j'encourage tout le monde
à aller le voir donc c'est le samedi
soir actuellement théâtre la flèche
d'affaires oui c'est ça mais sharon ou
non le 11e temps faim voilà et bah
écoutez on en ressortira conscient c'est
déjà pas mal
si on l'oublié un grand merci monsieur a
très vite et plein succès à votre
spectacle et une longue vie merci voilà
bravo à bientôt au revoir à tous merci
de nous avoir suivi et à très vite
non
[Musique]